y tenemos que prepararnos para el
próximo huracán esas fueron las palabras
del presidente joe biden a la comunidad
de la plaza en nueva orleans que quedó
devastada por el paso del huracán aida
el reto del mandatario será impulsar el
regreso del servicio eléctrico para
miles de afectados y garantizar bienes
de primera necesidad para los
damnificados en el menor tiempo posible
los líderes de la comunidad toda la
gente que está aquí hemos estado
trabajando para entregar millones de
comidas y litros de agua y se se que
están frustrados por el tiempo que se
tarda en restablecer la electricidad es
un trabajo peligroso dangers world al
menos 600.000 personas están sin agua
una situación que se suma al intenso
calor que genera una humedad sofocante
para sus habitantes ha sido una tormenta
tremendamente devastadora vamos a tardar
mucho en recuperarnos la parte inicial
consiste en estabilizar la vida de la
gente y salvar vidas
luego la recuperación va a continuar
durante bastante tiempo
luego de su paso por luisiana aid avanzó
hacia el noreste del país provocando
lluvias torrenciales e inundaciones
repentinas generalizadas que afectaron a
los ciudadanos de estados como
pensilvania
nueva jersey connecticut y nueva york-
miles de personas quedaron atrapadas en
sus automóviles y entre las víctimas se
cuentan personas que no pudieron salir
de los sótanos de sus casas ante las
inminentes catástrofes ambientales que
han azotado a eeuu autoridades de nueva
york y nueva jersey han mencionado que
es necesaria una preparación de la
infraestructura urbana así como un mejor
sistema de notificación de alertas el
presidente joe biden insistió en la
necesidad de que el congreso dé luz
verde a su plan de infraestructura